when you talk about you being a bruce
springsteen fan don't you get like the
bruce springsteen fanzine he is the only
friend that i have
to which i subscribe to a fanzine about
you know so it's like
but is it weird like when you're hanging
out with bruce and you're recording or
doing a live show do you have to
control your enthusiasm to be cool like
to like
so that you don't become this [ __ ] i
would say the first the first
you know 20 times or so maybe that but
it has gotten to the place where it is
it is
it is more comfortable the original
ghost of tom joad is like an acoustic
ballad from
his acoustic record then rage did like a
uh
you know ramped up sabbathy version of
that song
but the first time we actually played
that song was in in 2008 and
he was making the magic record with
brendan o'brien i stopped by the studio
and he said you know tommy you should
come play with the e street band
sometime
he said it as an offhand remark and i
took it as scripture so the next time
the next time they were in in anaheim i
you know i called him up the day before
i said
like uh remember when you said i should
jam with the e street man how about
tomorrow night
and we agreed on ghosted tom joe now at
the time the only version of his that
existed was the plaintiff
minor key ballot right now i've was as
nervous for this as i've ever been for
anything in my life i've played
many shows in many arenas and stadiums
and things like that i've never been
more nervous than prior to this
rehearsal explain to me nervous because
you're a masterful musician in other
words you know you're going there you're
going to play the ghost of tom joad
what do you do do you put the record on
and play along with it is that happening
all night all night long i get down
there i'm down in catering i hear the
band rehearsing it
and to my surprise bruce has raised the
key of the song
by eight steps now now i no longer can
play it and i no longer can sing it
because i've got this you know kind of
rich milk chocolate baritone voice and
it's too it's too high for me now
so i go up there and i'm on stage and i
don't know the chords and i can't hit
the notes and it's my first time
with my favorite artist on the stage and
it's not going great so steve vanzant
lovely dude he comes over and he's like
you know the way he's like baby
baby you know i'm like babe there's no
baby it's bad baby
because i don't know how to play the
song but they don't call bruce
springsteen the boss for nothing
so bruce comes over he recognizes my
anxiety
he puts a hand on my shoulder he says
tommy first of all i think i love the
fact that bruce springsteen calls me
it's small does anyone else call you
tommy besides my mom my mom calls me
what's his hand on my shoulder looks me
in the eye he says we're gonna do it in
this key
and it's gonna be great and i'm like
okay well thanks jedi master yoda but i
still don't know how to play it or sing
it
but it does calm my nerves and i
recognize that there's like 15 people in
the history band they know the chords i
don't need to worry about that
can i sing a song of social justice and
mean it yes i can
can i play guitar solo i can do that too
so right
they surprised me with the key so i
decided to
have a little surprise for the e street
band during the rehearsal
on the stage during soundcheck i don't
give anything away in the solo i just
play straight like chuck berry
blues licks you know through the whole
time i pedal
i pedal downstairs i'm down there half a
bottle of jameson later it's my turn to
come up
i walk on the stage and we played a
version of the song that
really took us all completely by
surprise and it was electric the thing
that bruce bruce is very generous in
that
you know i'm playing this crazy solo and
he's just like keep going keep going
keep going it's 82 bars
the roof comes off the place and we
looked at each other and i was like
bruce uh you were right about the key
after all what's the right key for this
one